The joe rogan experience go shows. You
got more notes. How do I smelled it?
I just wanted to finish
that thing about MMA. Um,
I want to ask you about
little tag. Yeah. Who Was it?
I did that for Jamie little,
a nine year old shit talker who flashes
money and it talks about her, uh,
Bentleys and rolls Royces for nine
years old and years old. It's fake.
She's her parents talk her
into it. So, so, but anyway,
MMA for me is a music modern
modernization act. Okay.
So about five, about five, six
years ago, Dean will uphold,
and I just started looking at that and
she's beautiful blonde lawyer, woman,
great woman, very smart, very intelligent.
Speaks over here at Brandeis or somewhere.
She's my lawyer,
was my manager for the longest time,
but she and I decided to go to Washington
has started flashing this shit around
saying, you know, what's fair and what's
not? Why or musician is not getting paid.
Right. So I just thought
MMA, it's the same thing.
Music modernization. So I won't forget
this. I sometimes forget it cause my,
you know, I forget. So to
attain fair market value,
royalty rates and treatment for music
creators in the digital era. The GJ,
the digital era right now is where if I,
they can play my music because
it's digital over air. You know,
Spotify and Adam could pay the
artists. Fuck me, I got enough money.
I'm the happiest guy who came along.
I got kids.
I go to sleep fucking
with a smile on my face.
I get to do Joe fucking Rogan.
Well,
I'm happy you just recognize a band name,
full name Aerosmith with Joe Perry.
I'm happy as can be right,
but I look at these poor fucks victim.
You got to hear this well today too. They
get, they have to give up merchandise.
They have to give up a piece
of their concert sales. Oh,
they have to give up
everything. Well, yeah,
that's what's going on because there's
no more money in actual records sale.
It's called a 24 seven or some kind of
bullshit was that crazy thing where they
have a piece of everything because
managers see it and they want your money.
Well, they also realize that
their avenue of revenue was gone.
So then they locked onto merchandise.
They locked on to ticket sales,
which used to be all yours, right? Yep.
Like when you used to do
concerts back in the day,
you used to get paid for your record.
And even if you got fucked over,
you got some money from the record,
but then you would get all the money
for the concerts. Right? But, but well,
not unless we were own managers.
90 10 means we take 90% out.
10% of the gift goes through there.
So you make $800,000 a night
company gets it. Oh God,
that's different. Right? Isn't
that a different thing? Well,
the record company gets,
gets publishing,
you know who with all these digital
outlets, of course. And then the,
then the record company company decides
to give whatever's left to the artist,
which is usually little to nothing.
Smoky fucking Robinson. My dear friend,
I go up to this guy and
I go, ah, don't you,
but I love you seemed if that guy,
all these songs, phenomenal. Oh,
this fucking guy went to the digitals
said you only $250,000 with roof they
offered. They offered for this
for his music being played.
Why the last five years? Why do
they owe him that? Because he,
because he was getting nothing back.
Nothing was coming to him. He's gone. She,
the coffers are empty.
You know what I'm saying is what the fuck?
I'm smokey Robinson, right. I hear my
music, his music is covered by hunt.
Thousands of people.
The guy knew legally $250,000
was owed to him. Okay,
okay.
He was offered 12,000 and he was said,
if you don't like it, sewers now smokey,
you don't have that kind of money.
So what we've done, the smokey Robinson
doesn't have that kind of money. So,
so what, what? Smokey Robinson
should be just wealthy. Look at King.
And this is not to say he's not.
If he had no money at all,
he's one of the happiest guy and his wife
is his sweetest and maybe he's a town
attain something that you and I know
recognize yet or, or the mass media.
But he's got something, he's rich.
But when it comes to him getting paid,
actually for songs,
that's really fucked up.
So we decided to do a, I don't
know, I don't know where it's going.
I've got to talk to him.
But David is real light.
The president and CEO of the National
Music Publishers Association and Dina,
we went to, went to Washington magic,
this beautiful blonde in this fucking guy.
Now we're in Washington in me, you
know, saying, what's up with this?
This money is going right out the
window and knocked to the artist.
These new artists getting nothing.
So we decided to do something for
the first time songwriters will have
representatives overseeing
administration of mechanical licenses and
administration.
So someone's now,
at least not only can he complain that
there's someone watching the goes, no, no,
no, no. You do. In fact
legally owned 250,000 smoke.
You can mirror sound
and for the first time.
So this is something we're
trying to get passed in the next.
Don't you think it should be
that? No, I do think, you know,
that's the reason why we're not on that.
We're not on Spotify and the
reason why we're not honest,
because it didn't make any sense.
They were like,
we want to put you on W it's going to be
great for you. I'm like, how's it? Great.
Yeah, you guys are going to make
money like you guys are making money.
You don't give us any.
It's that whole streaming thing is this
weird smoking mirrors song and dance
they put on, you're going to be a part
of something big. You're like, yeah,
but what are you selling?
All you sell is artists' work.
You don't have anything to
sell. Yup. And I seen him.
The artists get paid so little, so
little. So where's the money going?
Because there's all these
ain't never fucking pockets.
Public companies and they're traded and
they're worth millions and billions.
Like where's all that money? Where's
it going? What's generating it?
Can you need to say to them, what if
I'm bigger than you aren't motherfucker,
motherfucker. Well, 19 Oh nice.
The laws were written. Check this
out. Do you know nine on track?
I'm like not paid attention to until
fucking yesterday. Yesterday. I mean,
you know, five, five weeks ago,
so we're trying to get this shit go
gains momentum and the Senate, oh,
old smokey Robinson. Powerful yesterday.
Yesterday. Jesus Christ. Jamie,
you're on the ball. Wow. So this is it
right here. I mean, you know. Well, yeah,
there's been some fuckery. There's been
some legal fuckery and he, you know,
he created magic. This
guy. I said, I said to him,
what do you mean? I like
you, but I love you.
Seems that I'm always thinking of you.
I said,
where the fuck did you come up with a
line? Like I've said to Paul, you know,
what was, what was this?
You know, he says, well,
I was sent to New York to do some kind
of publishing thing with lawyers and I
was sitting in a hotel in New York
right before I went in and I thought,
I wrote those lyrics.
Somehow.
Him being a young black men with songs
50 years ago in New York with lawyers,
probably white,
not just saying he was put in a
situation where he had the magic,
he had the magic. He wrote a paper,
I don't like you. I love you.
It seems like maybe the hate that he
had for what was about to happen created
the opposite. I don't know, but
that's what he told me. He said,
I was down there and waiting to meet
my lawyers and I'm, I said that,
let me ask you is you never know when,
when Napster came along,
I fucking hated that prick.
Yeah.
You see they started stealing
our songs. Yeah. Great.
Take all the albums we've ever done.
Take all the albums. Nuno court and nick,
all the albums that fucking,
you know,
the rolling stones ever did
put them in a box over there.
Now all my friends can have access
to that box. Anybody can do it.
It's peer to peer.
Everyone's sharing songs
and I'm sure people who are
listening to me now and say,
what a prick. He's fucking ritual. Fuck.
But what's happened is
it's become the norm. Well,
it's,
let's be scared of norm is that people
recognize that you can't do that with
movies. Right. They recognize that if
you're stealing movies, it's illegal.
Like if you get caught
with a bit torn account,
you've got a bunch of movies on there
and you're letting people download them,
you can get prosecuted.
Yeah.
Let me ask you why so much for that
and not for somebody songs? Well,
there is a thing with songs too, but
it's just not as common. Right, Jamie,
is that the case? Would people have been
sued for having tons of songs? Right,
for sure. The movie industry has
gone after that. You go after you
if you're doubling their movie.
It's just songs for whatever reason,
after Napster became something that people
think that you should just be able to
get for free and then passing me on the
sick and Spotify and what's the other
one? Spotify and what's the
other? There's another one.
Titles getting in trouble right now,
whose title?
The company that Jay z
and with a few other,
they're getting charged for streaming
to funding streams and not paying people
and all that. I mean, it's just think
about some new bay. My daughter Chelsea,
she's in a band with John Foster,
her husband.
They put something out and it's
fucking ridiculously great. What?
Where's the money go? Well,
this is what I'm saying to you.
When Napster came along
and then things change,
do you think that's when the
music business really got crazy?
That's when they really say,
look, we've got to start.
We're not getting money from record
sales anymore. When the record business,
they can do the shit digitally. We've
got to get a piece of that concert sales.
We've got to get it, pick a piece of
those tickets. We've got to get the merge,
we gotta get everything we've got to
solidify and we've got to make it still
make it a big deal.
And the quick stream monies pricks
in the money grabbers from artists.
Just rethink.
Yeah,
streaming through streaming and streaming
seems like a more hostile version of
it. But let me ask you, who do you think
it's the money at the end of the day?
Somebody, executives. It goes somewhere.
You know when I watched this movie
called Vinyl, you see that vibe.
I haven't seen a documentary on whatever.
When it was out for a bit
and Mick Jagger and uh,
daisy Scorsese or Martin Scorsese,
they did a pretty good job.
They just got too into the characters
brain going fucking crazy, right?
And not enough of what was really
going on. It was in near falls, right?
Mick Jagger's,
Solon was called the squeaky parts.
There's the nasty parts and it showed
the managers snort and blow and thinking
how they can fucking take this and that.
It was so easy.
All the money was coming in to them.
They were making deals with were the
nasty parts weren't even signed to the
label,
but you hear them were assigned to the
manager and the manager had a secret deal.
Right.
Sony.
But you hear that about boxers have
in shitty everybody. Creepy managers.
You hear it about musicians,
comedians, you, everything.
I hope there's kids out there
right now listening to this.
They want to become lawyers and say,
did it, it should be the wild wild west.
Cause these nights it could be new.
A new type of lawyer.
Okay.